ces derniers se brider de la saison
fallait faire mieux que de taper sur le
écouter pour ce dernier ce crédit de
l'année et on en a assez de ce brésil
cette année il ya beaucoup de choses que
j'aime dans la vie et dont vous êtes au
courant il ya plusieurs choses aussi
dont vous n'êtes toujours pas au courant
et parmi ces choses se trouve ma passion
que maxence a aussi celles aussi l'a
d'ailleurs je les balances direct moi je
balance il ya pas de problème pour les
trucs qui ont un design un peu les un
peu horrible exemple concret vous voyez
les boutiques de souvenirs
il y en a partout quand tu voyages a
toujours des boutiques de souvenirs on
est d'accord que ça contient parmi les
pires objets jamais créée par l'homme
ben mecs j'adore voir ces objets ça me
tue de rire je me suis mis à
collectionner les aimants là qu'ils se
foutent sur le frigo et partout où je
vais je trouve le plus laid de tous et
je leur amène et je suis tellement
heureux et les rares fois où j'ai oublié
de passer en acheter un dans une
boutique de souvenirs j'étais dégoûté
entre j'attends vraiment j'étais abattu
pourquoi voyager si tu ne ramène pas un
aimant dégueulasse à l'arrivée ça n'a
pas de sens bref aujourd'hui j'aurais
dit c'est au foulkes bottes great
exécute des goûts du jeu las mais une
très bonne application vous le savez
peut-être pas mais y'a des trucs que
vous adorez qui sont dans la catégorie
mauvais goût et pourtant vous les adorez
moi aussi donc je vous le dis dame ans
il ya des trucs que je vais trouver trop
bien et vous allez détester et à des
trucs que je vais détester et vous allez
trouver génial c'est pas mal si les
goûts et les couleurs
un bon moyen d'être sûr que personne ne
vole mon bagage sa us parfaitement tous
que c'est dégueulasse mais je veux aussi
à des proches qui regarda offrez moi ça
je fais le fou sur clément ce prêt fait
un montage où il ya une tête à web sur
la valise si je suis convaincu geagea
s'est donc comment se faire tuer par la
police quelle idée de mer c'est pas ce
style et c'est pas pratique et c'est
dangereux à dieu comme pistolet
moi j'ai des problèmes pour me faire
entendre barbier n'en dis pas plus c'est
un mec je suis un peu jaloux
ça doit être tellement satisfaisant de
se toucher les cheveux quand et comme ça
on dirait vraiment la bonette du jour
smb 7 que tous vos streamer est pas mal
youtuber préféré on c'est incroyable
attend une vidéo de sept minutes card
mais vous croyez quoi
après qu'on a votre temps alors le spoil
c'est un gars qui a des tas et des tas
et des tas de noms et qui décide avec
ses montres de les vendre de les
collectionner nom de faire une table
c'est pourri avec kc mouassa de l'écran
là désolé ça m'a énervé tellement c'est
horrible un mauvais design de toilettes
à temps c'est ce que je pensais j'adore
j'adore ces trois au pire tu oppresse
tout ce que tu as vite chez toi c'est un
plaisir
c'est une idée géniale et vous savez
pourquoi je trouve c'est une idée
géniale c'est parce que quand je fais la
grosse commission ça et ça devient très
personnel très vite je reste aux
toilettes genre 25 minutes et les gens
se demandent ce que je fais aux
toilettes
yao qu'une plus grande zone de paix que
les toilettes mais qui est donc cette
déco un peu stressante et oppressante me
permettrai d'écourter un peu ce moment
là et de ne plus passer pour un drogué
auprès de certains amis lowrider
batmobile c'est dégueulasse c'est
dégueulasse je n'arrive pas à trouver
vous trouvez ça stylet c'est subjectif à
vous avez droit trouvait ça stylet vous
avez juste pas de goût il ya pas de
soucis mais promet vous trouvez à stylet
ça me rend malade là j'aurais dû faire
en live cette vidéo je feu des réponses
à mes questions
je suis en train de trouver ça cool je
vais en train de trouver ça cool j'ai
honte de moi heureusement j'ai pas de
marque de vêtements je serai à chier
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale il y
avait un masque à gaz
mickey qui avait été fabriqué pour
rendre le masque un peu moins effrayant
pour les enfants je suis désolé jamais
je le mets jamais tu le mets tu perds
ton âme il te possède il est beaucoup
plus fluide guerre vrai basque non
excusez moi mais ça avait beaucoup plus
peur que ça largement a enfin un truc
qui va tous nous mettre d'accord c'est
dégueulasse à temps des pauses pouces je
viens de réaliser qu'il ya trop d'image
qui vont pas nous mettre d'accord genre
certains parmi nous vous trouvez ça
horrible et d'autres vous trouvé ça
génial si les goûts et les couleurs on
ne se bat pas dans les commentaires
s'il vous plaît d'accord voilà c'est mon
propre emploi
non non menacées c'est interdit une
voiture recouvert de velours
ces hideuses je suis pas gentil je
n'accepte pas que les hôtes et des goûts
différents des miens je suis je suis pas
gentil fils désole mais qu'est ce qui se
passe les gars il faut arrêter de
vouloir absolument relier votre coupe de
cheveux à votre barbe c'est ça ne marche
pas quoi ça marche pas ça fait pas futur
steve énorme c'est pas beau imaginez
dans 15 ans est à la mode
comment vous allez me le ressortir cet
extrait bande de chiens dieu
il s'est fait tatouer une règle alors là
je n'arrive pas à savoir si ces coupes
ou pas je crois que l'aspect pratique du
truc fait que je trouve ça peut-être un
peu cool je suis désolé en fait si le
gars est pas ce sont tout son temps du
matin au soir à pêcher gens c'est la
passion de sa vie pas franchement fait
hausser grave pratique d'avoir une règle
sur ton mot les genres bien j'étais
juste condamné avec tu ne pêche pas à
mettre des pantalons jusqu'à la fin de
tes jours mais qui a eu le temps de
faire ça
j'adore j'adore j'adore ça me rappelle
des fois dans certains hôtels après
qu'il eut le passage du ménage la
feuille de pq dans les toilettes et la
première elle est pliée en mode stylet
et tous à chaque fois j'adore puisque
j'ai un truc à regarder pendant mes 25
minutes ou fait est ce que tu peux
donner à mon vin de l'air d'avoir 20 ans
mercy non alors non ne faites pas
l'erreur café abad migraine est ce qu'on
la rêve si les vieux objets sont
charmants c'est parce que c'est des
vieux objets si vous reproduisez la
gueule d'un vieil objet sur un objet qui
est neuf
ce n'est pas le même effet est ce que je
fais un coup de gueule qui concerne 0,1
pour cent des gens qui regardent cette
vidéo est évidemment l'illusion optique
de cette coupe de cheveux
non mais arrêtez avec vos coupes de
cheveux la journée ma non mais attends
c'est pas une illusion il a vraiment le
crâne a dansé ok c'est une news moi je
fais ça pour de vrai l'arrière du crâne
ici j'ai jean une sorte de relief
bizarre et quand les coiffeurs et passe
la tondeuse
il bute sur la bosse et en plus de me
faire mal ça craint vieux au monde
malaise que le coiffeur il comprend pas
pourquoi ce relief à cet endroit là il
n'a jamais vu ça mais ils n'osent pas me
parler au nom c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
un tatouage vous savez comme certaines
oeuvres dans la rue qui joue sur la
perspective où tu crois que c'est réel
mais lui l'a fait sous forme de tatouage
dans sa main pour faire croire qu'il a
dans sa main une poignée de graines de
tournesol des phares chandelier
bah c'est pas homologué tout simplement
en cas d'accident tu n'es plus assurée
donc non je suis désolé je suis très
terre à terre mais bon une vidéo il ya
une vidéo
j'avais oublié que des fois ya vu des
vidéos oh non il fait des tapis de
voiture en mode faux gazon
[Musique]
j'associe l'herbe au caca de chien
systématiquement quand je marche dans
l'herbe je marche dans un cat tien parce
qu'il ya des trous du cul qui ramassent
pas la mère de leur chien autant vous
dire que si je monte dans cette voiture
je vais passer le trajet à avoir peur de
marcher dans un caca de chien c'est
relou je comprends l'intention de
vouloir faire un truc un peu nature
mignon mais c'est de la fausse arme en
plastique et ça nous rappelle les quatre
chiens c'est un non mais arrêtez je suis
désolé mais ça suffit
arrêtez de relier vos cheveux à votre
barbe il en a ras le cul bordel ça c'est
alors ça c'est vraiment du genre dans
les farces et attrapes une cuvette où
dans la cuvette ya plein de punaise
c'est vraiment à farces et attrapes
alors ça c'est un truc qui se fait
énormément j'ai acheté d'ailleurs au
japon dès magnette qui représente de la
bourse japonaise je sais trop bien ce
genre et elle mange tout ça coule par
contre sur un format à coque de
téléphone non non non non quoi
mais arrêtez arrêtez de mettre un autre
solde en voiture mais les gars les tapis
de voiture ils sont super ils font très
bien taf quelle idée de carles et sa
voiture c'est dingue ce trop bizarre
[Musique]
c'est une tirelire mais mes coups cdn
c'est au japon pourquoi ça veut pas ça
me dégoûte
[Musique]
je suis perdu je ne sais plus qui je
suis non alors ça nord des ongles
huîtres mais c'est maintenant il n'y a
plus rien de bien là c'est terrible
les galets gallega n'y a plus rien de
bien c'est hallucinant regardez moi
cette merde
il a redit je me permets excusez moi
mais je sais que personne ne peut aimer
ça c'est pas possible tu aimes le voir
dans un airbnb qu'tu alloué une nuit et
encore tu es déçu quand tu tombe dessus
n'est pas chez toi à quel point ces
escaliers ne sont pas des escaliers on
attendait en tout cas c'est beau
franchement il ya un petit côté futur
mais ça fait un peu cheap passer à des
notes trop dur est et surtout tu meurs
deux semaines après les avoir installés
c'est évident les marchés sont pas
droites mais quelle horrible idée la
nuit tu va aux toilettes c'est fini tu
vas dans ton cercueil en fait
directement géant faire un tee shirt de
mauvais goût savez les tee-shirts ou
bien où il ya de vieilles phrase de ce
nul là j'ai envie de refaire un genre je
peux pas je doit relier macouba barbe
n'a en fait ce serait nul il ya des gens
ils en ont rien à [ __ ]
c'est incroyable regardez moi ce gars à
quel point il en a rien à [ __ ]
kevin tu n'es jaune jeu tu affrontes
quand tu veux sur le crâne de ce mec tu
veux
oh attendez non là j'adore c'est un
lustre il est incroyable mais c'est
comme la voiture velours là on dirait
des objets d'animal crossing
j'adore en photo mais je le mets ou chez
moi bah je peux pas c'est trop chaud ou
alors faut que toute la pièce pas dans
un tel précis qui va dans ce délire là
mais franchement je le vois une
exposition je passe devant je fais whaou
mais je l'achète pas à aucun moment
j'aime bien j'aime bien franchement
j'aime je t'avais hier j'ai jamais
autant galéré à assumer le fait que
j'aime bien un truc là que pendant cette
vidéo c'est dur de base dans la vie de
dire j'aime ça c'est beaucoup plus
simple de dire ça je déteste ça c'est
nul mais là c'est un autre level 1
franchement c'est dur
eh bien écoutez j'ai adoré tellement
d'objets ya tellement truc que j'ai
trouvé cool je suis désolé mais il ya un
côté attirant dans le mauvais goût et
même expression même mauvais goût elle
est hyper subjectif en fait il ya des
trucs qui vont être du mauvais goût pour
certains à mort et que d'autres vont
faire annoncer un peu cool bref je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi ce dernier se
brident j'espère qu'il vous aura plu
j'adore faire mais c'est vrai dit
j'adore à chaque fois rebondi on discute
de trucs et tous enfin vrai je fais des
grands monologues mais je veux j'arrive
à imaginer vos réponses est ce que vous
vous dites et je suis passé un bon
merci pour ce bon moment une fois de
plus à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
cette jambe
[Musique]